when you head under the sea sometimes
magic happens in unexpected ways this
surprised cameo in The Little Mermaid
has fans singing with joy spoilers ahead
the live-action remake of The Little
Mermaid boasts an impressive cast and
dazzling musical numbers led by Halle
Bailey's acclaimed performance as Ariel
so far fans on Twitter have had positive
reactions that align with the early
reactions from critics and moviegoers
they also praise Melissa McCarthy's
Lively portrayal of Ursula the sea witch
as well as a surprising and delightful
Cameo the original animated classic
premiered in 1989 and introduced Ariel
as a beloved icon given the importance
of the character it was only right to
include a very special guest during the
second half of the 2023 reimagining
after Ursula's Sinister spell transforms
the young Mermaid Ariel ascends to the
surface of the ocean on her new legs she
reconnects with Prince Eric and enjoys a
colorful day in the Royal Kingdom while
sampling the many offerings on land
among the welcoming locals one helpful
vendor happens to be none other than
Jody Benson who voiced Ariel in the
original animated treasure even though
Ariel is unable to speak during this
exciting exchange Jody Benson's
captivating presence more than makes up
for it it isn't immediately clear that
Benson is playing the market vendor but
the sound of the original Ariel's voice
will certainly have the audience's ears
perked up before her big reveal
it recognized a lot as the voiceover she
holds up a fork and tells Ariel she may
be needing it Ariel then misuses the
renowned dingle hopper by running it
through her hair in both versions of The
Little Mermaid the seagull Scuttle
mistakes the instrument for a comb just
a little squirrel here and I yank them
boy oh like as Benson gives her the
fitting gift it also feels like a
passing of the torch moment between the
two actresses that crowns bayley as the
new Ariel this loving inclusion pays
tribute to Benson's heartfelt depiction
while also celebrating bayley's
groundbreaking role in a story about
combining two worlds this is a wonderful
interaction that seamlessly threads the
two versions of The Little Mermaid
together the scene in which Hallie
Bailey's Ariel receives the dinglehopper
was always present in the script but the
idea of bringing Benson in manifested a
bit later while discussing her Cameo
with Entertainment Weekly Benson
expressed just how excited she was to
return to the world of The Little
Mermaid and work with director Rob
Marshall her friend for over four
decades it was just a huge thrill for me
when Robbie reached out I'm like of
course I'm gonna come I don't care what
I'm doing I just can't wait to get
around the set and watch all of you work
for Marshall it was important to fold
Benson into the film in a way that felt
organic and not stunty the director also
told the outlet that having the two
Aerials on set was a major win that
brought the cast and crew together The
Little Mermaid continues to receive
praise for its lead performances with
Hallie Bailey consistently singled out
for her take on Ariel while Bailey is
receiving her fair share of love from
Disney fans across the world it's Jody
Benson's approval that has her jumping
for joy Bailey talked about Benson in a
chat with the Los Angeles Times saying
she told me how proud she was of me and
how I'm handling everything and
encouraged me to just go for it I
appreciate her for being so warm and
welcoming to me because she's the goat
and it was important to me to get her
stamp of approval
foreign
[Music]